18:13 and the netherlands is part of the
first french empire its emperor napoleon
the first wasn't doing so well and was
retreating from the coalition armies the
next year within the Netherlands a riot
broke out against French rule and a man
called gisbert karel van Hagen dub
formed a provisional government this
government proclaimed a man called
William Frederick of the House of Orange
as their Sovereign Prince so Napoleon
lost against the coalition allies and
was exiled never to be seen again after
this the fate of the newly independent
Netherlands was left to the British the
reason for this was that during the
Napoleonic Wars Britain had seized the
Dutch colonial empire for itself one was
unsure how much to give back
however Britain's new foreign policy for
Europe was being formulated at the
Congress of Vienna it was centered
around establishing a new balance of
power in which the Netherlands would
play a crucial role the problem laid to
itself the territory previously known as
the Austrian Netherlands the British
wouldn't let Prussia or France have it
since that would make them too powerful
and if it was independent that it
wouldn't stand much of a chance in the
event of war and since the Austrians did
want it back it was decided that it
would be incorporated into the brand-new
United Kingdom of the Netherlands
William Frederick was proclaimed William
the first and also made the Grand Duke
of Luxembourg the hope was that this new
kingdom would be able to resist any
aggresses and prevent France or Prussia
from becoming too powerful to bolster
the new Kingdom's finances the British
returned the Dutch Empire to William
there were two caveats though one
Britain would keep Cape Colony in two in
return for their empire the Netherlands
would ban the slave trade which they did
this new Kingdom had a couple of
domestic issues though notably the fact
that the southern Netherlands had a
large Catholic and french-speaking
population so there was little to tie
them together
that was until Napoleon came back he was
reinstated as the French Emperor marched
his army into the Netherlands where he
met a new coalition at the Battle of
Waterloo Napoleon lost now this new
kingdom had a unifying foundation
story.this couldn't wash away the
religious differences though and so
William invited the southern Nobles to
vote on a notion of religious equality
throughout the kingdom
unfortunately for William they voted no
William however devised an ingenious
plan to get around this he ignored their
complaint and counted all of their votes
as yeses William was a much gentler
ruler than Napoleon had been but that's
not to say he tolerated much dissent and
he was quick to censor the press when it
criticized him over the next decade
Williams policies didn't really please
anyone
he chose Dutch as the kingdom's official
language which annoyed the French
speakers in the south he wanted both
religions to be equal yet subservient to
the state which annoyed everyone he was
his economic policies that
really upset those living in the south
though taxes were raised to pay for the
kingdom's debt and around half of the
country's tax revenue came from the
south yet only about 30% of government
spending went to it which felt like
money was simply being funneled to the
north it actually wasn't not really it
was simply being funneled to the king in
his inner circle hundreds of thousands
of people in the south petitioned the
king to address their issues in the late
1820s but they got nothing from him
tensions in the south continued to rise
until the 25th of August 1830 in which
rioting broke out in Brussels this came
just after the Bourbon dynasty in France
was ousted by similar riots in Paris
the Wrights in Brussels soon turned to
revolution and the royal government in
its troops were soon forced north the
southern Netherlands then declared
itself to be an independent nation
taking the name Belgium taken from the
regions name in Latin the great powers
of Europe eyeing the situation with
great interest in the end though no
great power got involved since Britain
decided to host the London conference in
late 1830 to decide what would be done
neither the Dutch nor the Belgians were
invited in case you were wondering the
French proposed that they would annex
this territory Prussia would gain
Luxembourg in all of this and the rest
of the South would be formed into a
British protectorate this was firmly
rejected by Britain because France
wasn't allowed to have nice things
instead the great powers recognized the
independence of Belgium which would also
include this territory taken from
Luxembourg Belgium would also get itself
a fancy new King Leopold the first
chosen because he had no ties to either
France or Prussia William the first and
the Dutch didn't accept this agreement
and instead decided to invade the south
and take the provinces back by force his
army defeated the new and poorly
organized Belgian army but was forced to
turn back after only ten days when the
French sent their forces north to stop
him the Dutch held on to Maastricht in
Antwerp the latter of which was besieged
and captured by the French in 1832 this
meant that when William finally accepted
Belgian independence in 1839 he was
granted the territory of Limburg and was
made its Duke
so the United Kingdom of the Netherlands
was no more now there were two kingdoms
which had to find their way in Europe
after basically bankrupting itself the
Netherlands had to institute
constitutional reforms which William
couldn't accept and so he abdicated in
favor of his son will in the second as
for Belgium it's important to note that
the people who lived there did see
themselves as Belgians and there wasn't
much support for either reunification
with the north or for joining France
Belgium was largely seen though by the
great powers as little more than a
buffer state between France and Prussia
which is why it was declared to be
permanently neutral furthermore to
protect this neutrality Britain formally
gara
it's Independence a guarantee that
Britain would honor 75 years later I
hope you enjoyed this episode and thank
you for watching a special thanks to
James Bissonnette Ozark a flash Henry
Robin Winston Cawood Adam Harvey and
Skye Chappell
you